-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
Well, everybody, making jokes
during times like these
is difficult, but it's my job
to try and make people laugh
and feel better, even if just
for a little while.
So, with that in mind,
let's tell some jokes.
Last night, President Trump
made another stop
on his great American
COVID tour,
this time in Pennsylvania,
at the Pittsburgh
International Airport.
There was quite a turnout
at the airport rally.
Take a look at this photo.
For any parents watching,
if you ran out of
"Where's Waldo?" books for your
kids during quarantine,
just hand them this photo
and tell them to find
a Trump supporter
wearing a mask.
[ Laughter ]
You gotta give Trump credit
for one thing --
this had to be the first time
in history people were excited
to spend a Tuesday night
at the Pittsburgh airport.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was on stage
for 90 minutes,
and I think there was some
things he could've skipped,
like here when he questioned why
Joe Biden always wears a mask.
Listen to this.
-He feels good about the mask,
and that's okay.
You know what?
Whatever makes you feel good.
He feels good.
I mean, honestly, what the hell
did he spend all that money
on the plastic surgery
if he's gonna cover it up
with a mask?
[ Laughter ]
-Yep, according to those
closest to him,
Trump's never had any work done,
nor done any work.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Trump made fun
of Biden's plastic surgery.
Meanwhile, his handling
of the virus is about to appear
on an episode of "Botched."
[ Laughter ]
By the way, did you see which
network was airing the rally?
C-SPAN3.
You know
your campaign's going well
when even C-SPAN2 says,
"Nah, we're good."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, in an interview
that aired last night on WGN,
Trump was asked
what single quality
he brings to the White House,
and here was his response.
-Well, I think I bring an aura
that people know
I know what I'm doing.
I know what is happening.
I know where we should be going,
I negotiate properly.
I understand the military.
I understand things
as a businessman
that other people don't.
Just as a person,
I understand things.
-Yeah. Once again, the question
was, what single quality.
[ Laughter ]
Also, just because
you're glowing orange
doesn't mean you have an aura.
[ Laughter ]
"I have an aura-ge, orange."
That's right, Trump says
he knows what he's doing,
what is happening,
and where he should be going.
So, good news -- once again,
he passed concussion protocol.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously,
those are things you say
after a trainer
gives you smelling salts.
Well, guys,
we're just six days away
from the first
presidential debate,
and the topics Trump and Biden
will be discussing
have been announced.
Check it out.
-The moderator,
Fox News' Chris Wallace,
has selected the six topics
that will be discussed.
The topics include the
President's and Biden's records,
the Supreme Court, coronavirus,
economic policy, racism,
and the integrity
of the election.
-That wasn't a good sign
when Trump's response was,
"Pass, pass, pass,
pass, pass, and pass."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, when Trump heard,
he was like,
"I've got five more topics
that I'd love to talk about --
man, woman, person, camera,
and TV."
[ Laughter ]
Right now,
it's just those topics
and then the other
50 insane things that'll happen
between now and Tuesday.
Some more debate news,
although this one is about
the vice presidential debate.
It turns out Pete Buttigieg
has been standing in
as Mike Pence for
Kamala Harris's debate practice.
And to really get into the role
of Mike Pence,
Buttigieg also wears three pairs
of Hanes long underwear
safety pinned together.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Mike Pence,
yesterday, his plane,
Air Force Two,
was forced to return
to New Hampshire
after it struck a bird.
Actually, when Pence remembered
his debate against Kamala
is only two weeks away,
he started throwing more birds
into the engine.
He's like, "Stop! Stop.
Help, stop, please."
It's no surprise that birds
are attracted to Mike Pence.
He's basically the human version
of white bread.
[ Laughter ]
Changing gears here,
this week, the CDC
issued its first guidelines
for celebrating Halloween.
Listen to this.
-The CDC released
its recommendations
for Halloween,
and the biggest one is to avoid
traditional trick-or-treating
this year.
The CDC also pointed out
that costume masks
do not have the same protective
power as normal masks.
-Remember the good old days
when all you had to worry about
was a giant shiv
in your Snickers bar?
[ Laughter ]
The CDC is discouraging
trick-or-treating,
but to be fair, maybe children
shouldn't have been going around
collecting candy
from strangers anyway.
That's right,
no trick-or-treating.
It's too bad.
I'm really gonna miss
the disappointed look
on my kids' face
when they get an Almond Joy.
[ Laughter ]
I was fighting that joke.
I like Almond Joy. Yeah.
-Yeah, no trick-or-treating.
Kids will miss getting candy,
while parents will miss
giving that quick judgy glimpse
into their neighbor's house.
[ Laughter ]
"Carpet in the kitchen?"
"Very '70s."
Yep, the CDC is also
discouraging costume parties,
mainly so no one
has to look at the idiot
who dresses up
as the coronavirus.
"Really funny, Carl."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Halloween
will be different.
If you see a house
covered in cobwebs,
those aren't decorations.
Those are people who haven't
gone outside since March.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, some sports news.
A lot of people
are talking about
Bill Belichick's sweatshirt
from his press conference
this morning.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
Gosh, he looks like the Hulk
after turning back
into Bruce Banner.
[ Laughter ]
Even crazier,
that's his wedding tuxedo.
[ Laughter ]
I think that shirt
was also established in 1960.
I don't get it.
Was he putting out cigarettes
on his shoulder?
[ Laughter ]
He looks like the centerfold
in "Divorced Dad Monthly."
[ Laughter ]
Remember that photo,
'cause it's what Chris Wallace
is gonna look like
after Tuesday's debate.
[ Laughter ]